after the rocky start the latest five
nights at Freddy's game is now being
rereleased for free I'm Dave and welcome
to a jump-scare news update following
its controversial launched five nights
at freddies world has been re-released
but is now available for free on
gamejolt according to the developer
scott cawthon the updated version has a
remodeled overworld along with this the
re-release has many other new features
but these aren't detailed hawthorne says
there will be more updates to come five
nights at freddies world is an RPG
spin-off of the popular horror series
five nights at freddy's the originally
launched in January but was removed from
sale after complaint they had been
re-released too early and fell
unfinished this is an exactly
announcement that I'm enjoying writing
but it's one that I feel I owe to the
community you know I've been accused of
rushing my games ever since five nights
at freddy's one but I've never felt that
I'd released a game too early until now
he continued on to admit there were
features the game should have had before
release these included being able to see
what abilities do during battle or being
able to see a stats page for your
characters these are features that any
good RPG would have he said I got too
eager to show the things that were
finished that I neglected to pay
attention to the things that weren't I'm
going to fix this and I'll be updating
the game with these new features in the
coming weeks so I say this to a
community I've enjoyed and respected for
over a year and a half now I'm sorry I
will continue to add features to the
game and I will make it right the first
five nights Freddy's debuted in August
2014 on PC and has since been ported to
iOS three sequels have been really since
with the most recent being five nights
at Freddy's 4 arriving in July 2015 so
what are your thoughts about where five
nights at Freddy's is heading has it had
its day or do you want more terrifying
robotic animals let us know in the
comments section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and for all
your gaming news stay tuned to gamespot
com